Hey everybody, welcome to the content
video going over
variables and arithmetic.
We are gonna start in
section 2.2 of your textbook,
starting with variables, and then
we'll jump to section 2.3. And
just a quick note about these content
videos is that they are always
going to, most of the time, draw
from topics from the textbook,
but we don't always hit every
single section in the textbook, if
that makes sense. And so not only
can you watch the content videos,
you can also follow along with
the content in the textbook
and you can use the content video
repository code to help you learn
the subject matter as we go
throughout the course of semester.
We're going to start by talking
about variables and assignment. So
the main thing here is that variables
are how we store data in memory.
If you've ever taken something like
algebra maybe you learned about
you know a plus b equals c and a
and b c they all represent some
kind of a data, usually numbers in
the context of algebra, but some
kind of data that we're working
with. And in Python, variables are
going to represent all sorts of
things. They can represent objects,
they can represent data such as
numbers, they can represent strings,
booleans, and all sorts of
different data points like that. And
then the way that we assign
values to variables is through the
assignment operator, or as you
probably know it, the equals sign.
So it's important to know that
the equals sign is called the
assignment operator in Python.
And the difference comes up
a couple of times, especially
when we are testing for truth.
For example, in like an if
statement or an if else,
we would use a double
equals instead of a single
equals because the equals
is the assignment operator.
So let's jump over to
our GitHub repository.
And really quick, what I
wanted, I was actually looking
at how to do it here. I
wanted to have you guys
quickly change a setting before
we get too far into code.
In your code space here, I want you
to go ahead and search for disable AI
features and right here it comes up
chat disable AI features go ahead
and just check that box this will be
really helpful as you are learning
code so that you don't just have
an AI learn all of the code for
you so I'll go ahead and close that
there so what we're going to do
is we are actually going to code
a couple of things really quick
together in this code space for the
content video code and as you're as
you're watching the content videos
I recommend that you follow along
so that you can help yourself if
you're struggling with any of the
concepts. Some of the stuff in the
beginning might be a little bit of
review for you. If it's not, that's
fine. And if it is, that's great.
But as we go throughout the
course, the ideas in the content
videos will become a little
bit more complex and more
difficult. And so I recommend you
follow along with me as iCode.
And I've given you the content
video code repo so that you
can have access to all of this
code already written. But what
we're going to do is we're
going to start with variables.
So we already said that the equal
sign is the assignment operator.
So what we're going to
do is we're going to
just grab a variable.
Let's say, I don't know,
age. That's always an easy one. And let's
set it to some number. We'll choose 56.
So if I was to, for example, come down
here and say, let's print out age.
Run that code.
we'd see down here in
our output terminal here
is our age that's some
kind of data that has been
assigned to the variable age and is
now able to be printed out so pretty
straightforward there let's make
another one let's just call it vow
so this is just going to represent a
value value equals two we can print
out value as well we can do math
on value let's print it out for now
run that.
Here's our value and our age. Perfect.
One thing I wanted to specify for
you guys is that what if we've got
a variable called val that represents
age, but then I also wanted
to create another value using the
exact same naming convention, but
this time I want to set it to 5.
What happens to line 8 val equals 2
or val is assigned to 2? Well, what
happens is Python has a built-in
kind of system called garbage
collection that comes and it cleans
up old like memory assignments like
this old value. So, for example,
value equals 2 is overwritten
by value equal 5. And so value
equal 2 just kind of goes away
into garbage collection. It's
not really referenced anymore.
because if I was to use val now,
like printout val, the value
that I'm going to get is five.
Now you might be like, why do we
still get two? It's because value was
assigned to two on line nine, but
it gets reassigned on line 11. And
so this val at the end of our code
is all but gone and has been replaced
with a val equal five. So hopefully
that's not too confusing. think.
Let's talk a little bit
about naming conventions.
So you can have all sorts
of things that are variable
names. So maybe if we want
to name something spring one,
we'll call this hello
world. I can't spell.
Hello world.
That's a good naming convention.
You can always start something
with an underscore. So if I wanted
to say underscore variable one,
that can be equal to, I don't know,
ten.
We can do something like, I love
variables, very good name,
type, hang on, 3.1415, pi, that's great.
Let's specify a couple
different naming conventions.
So we've got something called camel case,
which looks like this uh something
like that and camel case is where
you don't capitalize the first
letter in a variable name but you do
capitalize all the letters of the
words preceding that you don't use a
space in between the different words
so that's camel case and then there's
also the other case that I use
more often I don't know what it's
called but I use it on line 17 it's
where you use an underscore between
your words. You can't use a space.
So if I tried to do something like
first space name equals Chelsea,
that Python won't let
me do that. You see how
we've got all sorts of
little squiggly lines saying
we don't like that? Yeah,
they don't like that.
So first name equals Chelsea.
What we would do instead is first
underscore name equals Chelsea
and that is more appropriate.
Again, don't really know what
that case is called. There's
probably a name for it. I'm not
going to look it up right now.
And let's see, I think
that's everything I wanted
to hit on with or to
touch on with variables.
So let's move on to arithmetic.
And I'm going to try really
hard to spell this right.
Arithmetic.
I'm cheating because I
have notes on the side.
And okay, this is section
2.3 of our textbook.
So the basic things I
wanted to talk about
here are addition,
subtraction, multiplication,
exponentation. Nobody calls
it that. They just call
it raising something to the
power of something else.
True division and floor
division. Oh, and then modulo.
So let me, I'm just going to copy
some stuff really quick because I
don't want to take all the time
to uh type all this out but we'll
just review it really quick so
let's say we have a variable called
age we'll say it's I don't know 30
is a boring age let's say it's 40
we like being 40 okay age equals
20 plus 20 is a basic example of
addition so we're taking a variable
and we are assigning it to the
results of a mathematical expression
that in English means we're adding
the two numbers together and
then we're assigning that to the
variable age. So then we're printing
out age. Same thing with subtraction.
So age equals age minus one. So
I'll let you kind of think in
your head what that should equal.
We'll run this code in just a minute.
So if we took age being 40 and
then subtracted one off of that.
We've also got multiplication.
So x is equal to
three times two. It's
pretty straightforward one.
Then we reassign x to a new value it
equals five divided by two and then
floor division is actually so let
me let me specify the differences
really quick right here so regular
division true division sometimes called
float division gives us a decimal
number so five divided by two it
does not divide evenly right and so
we've got five divided by two should
be 2.5 and so the result we would
get from float division is literally
2.5, a float, or a decimal number.
And then floor division is the same
idea. We divide some number by some
other number, but instead of getting
a decimal number, we actually lopped
that decimal off the back. So what
we would get from 5 floor divided
by 2 is actually just 2. So it's
asking how many times does this number
cleanly divide into the other number
without a remainder, okay and then
the modulus operator is kind of
the opposite of that one instead of
the number cleanly dividing into the
other we want to know just the
remainder so if I take five and mod it
by two I only want the remainder which
in this case should be uh remainder
one right because five divides into
two cleanly twice but then we get
one left over so let's run these
these uh multiplication expressions.
I don't know what that is. And you can
see here, so let's
scroll up a little bit.
Age equals 20 plus 20, that gives us 40.
Age is equal to age minus 1, gave us 39.
And then we got, where are
we? Multiplication, 3 times
2 is 6. Division, remember
this is float division,
gave us 2.5.
Floor division gave us two, and the
modulus operator gave us one. Okay,
one last note on arithmetic
before we wrap up
this video is that when
we do floor division, we
are always rounding down
to the nearest positive,
or sorry, we're always
rounding down. Okay,
so just remember that as we
go throughout the course.
And that's everything for
this video. Thank you.